this is the reason interview with Nick
Gillespie thanks for listening my guest
today is Rachel newer author of I Feel
Love MDMA and the Quest for Connection
in a fractured world it's a history of
the drug known as Molly and ecstasy
that's about to be approved by the FDA
as an aid in fighting
[Music]
PTSD Rachel newer thanks for talking to
reason thanks so much for having me um
why did you write I Feel Love great
question there's really two answers to
that uh the first is the sort of common
good answer which is there wasn't a book
about MDMA it's this uh huge cultural
phenomenon we're probably going to see
it well hopefully see it approved by the
FDA for PTSD treatment within the next
year yet there wasn't a resource that
brought all the information about this
complex Nuance drug together in one
place just felt like people needed to
have that Touchstone and you know
there's just so many misconceptions
about MDMA that I wanted to spell those
not just for readers but also for myself
the other part of that answer is a more
personal one it was the height of the
pandemic um like many people I was kind
of having a crisis you know what am I
doing with my life am I going in the
right direction and for me that was
really manifesting in worries over my
career I had spent about a decade
reporting about illegal Wildlife trade
which is not a cheery topic we're
talking like you know slaughtered rhinos
and elephants and there just weren't
many hopeful stories there and I was I
really realized that I was looking for a
change of pace for a new intellectual
and personal Challenge and MDMA turned
out to be the answer and that helps
explain the subtitle of the book right
which is MDMA and the Quest for
Connection in a fractured world yeah yes
so this is this is like your pandemic
baby this is yeah this is exactly that
it's kept me very occupied in the
pandemic and um you know my last book I
went to like 12 countries to report it
but this one I could very easily do from
the phone and just right here in the
good old us OFA and um a quick hop over
the pond to the UK there was certainly
that uh you know I think weirdly if we
we talk about the Psychedelic
Renaissance at reason and obviously
other people do but that that might be
one thing the pandemic really helped
because you couldn't travel out yep so
travel in right you know exactly yeah
and I I say this in the beginning of the
book so it's not a surprise but the idea
for the book came to me while I was on
MDMA but not at a club which is my
preferred environment for this sitting
on my couch at home at like you know 700
p.m. on a Friday night um just uh before
we get into the uh conversation about
the history of MDMA I'm I'm struck by
your saying you know this came to me
while I was on
MDMA as as a broad cultural background
how old are you I am let's see what am I
now 38 keeps changing yes it does on an
almost annual basis right it's crazy um
but one thing like have you always felt
comfortable saying hey you know what I
use drugs that are technically or you
know openly illegal um and have you
always felt comfortable doing that or is
there a shift going on in our society
where people are starting to say you
know what like these drugs are not
sanctioned or they're kind of sketchy or
people kind of look at weird but let's
talk about it yeah uh I was definitely
not always the person who's like I use
drugs I like drugs um I was a d kid from
the 80s I grew up just another great
success story indeed um yeah I
completely swallowed that me message I
internalized it um if I heard of friends
doing drugs you know whether it's weed
or ecstasy I looked down on them I
judged them I thought you know people
who do drugs are looking for an escape
or their burnouts or you know they're
going to frazzle their brain wasn't for
me um that began to change in college I
had a friend who introduced me to
mushrooms but I didn't really know
anything about them I didn't have this
stigma attached to it like ecstasy did
so I was like sure I'll try a new thing
I love new experiences um and that was
great really enjoyed it but it didn't
open my eyes to MDMA at all I still had
this negative connotation is it because
MD Ma I I suspect in Dare when you were
in grammar school they weren't talking
about mushrooms so much but is it is it
also because MDMA is engineered MDMA is
a pharmaceutical of some sort it's a
pill it's not a naturally occurring
thing I think for a lot of people that
is absolutely the case um for me I had a
personal negative connotation so when I
was my freshman year of college a
friend's brother committed suicide and
um this is in my town of Mississippi and
everyone BL blamed his use of ecstasy
they specifically said you know Chris he
was taking all this ecstasy you know it
made him so depressed and he killed
himself so instead of looking at the
underlying drivers of what led him to
make that decision everyone just pointed
at the drug and I you know my dare kid
self said okay yeah it must be this
awful ecstasy thing I'm never going to
touch that right um let's talk about the
uh kind of Discovery or rediscovery of
MDMA in what late 60s early 70s lay at
the the history of MDMA and for the
people out there you might know it as
Molly or ecstasy or Adam I mean but you
know what is MDMA and where did it come
from yeah that's a that's a great
disclaimer for everyone out there m and
ecstasy are the same thing and they
refer to what is supposed to be MDMA
whether your street bought Molly your
ecstasy is MDMA is another question but
they refer to the same thing it's just a
branding tactic um so the History part
of the book surprisingly was actually my
one of my favorite parts to write my
mom's a historian but I'm not a history
person myself and I just really got into
it because there were so many unexpected
twists and turns so um first of all MDMA
is a lot older than most people think it
was first synthesized well it was first
patented let's say on Christmas Eve 1912
by the German pharmaceutical company
Merc uh you know respected uh group um
and they weren't looking for something
to change people's brains were looking
for a blood clotting agent and MDMA was
just a chemical intermediary on the
steps they needed to get there whether
or not either that or they had a chemist
who just liked the way it felt and was
like yeah yeah yeah whatever yeah
exactly um very sadly the uh that
chemist was killed a few years later in
World War I so um anyway so MC whether
or not anyone there actually tried it we
don't know they've been really kg about
letting people into their archives um it
seems like like maybe they did there's
little hints here and there of chemists
being like hey this is pretty
interesting let's uh take a closer look
um fast forward to the 1950s MDMA pops
up in the US for the first time uh this
is during the US government search for
chemical truth serum so to's figure out
how we can control the minds of our
enemies by um conducting experiments on
US citizens to see how this goes right
so this is part of MK Ultra and it's the
EP
it
wasn't yeah it was the Army's version of
the cia's trials um uh again we don't
have the sort of Smoking Gun evidence
that MDMA was ever given to anyone under
this um this experiment but there's a
lot of circumstantial evidence um people
who have had more time than I have to
pursue the um Freedom of Information Act
process uh have gotten really close to
revealing that that indeed the US Army
did do this um a a a student named
Nicholas denome I think he's gotten his
PhD now so Dr Nicholas denome um tracked
down a document that pointed to tulan
University in New Orleans um as having
contracted with the Army and MDMA was on
their list of drugs but when uh Nick
asked for the specific document from the
US government that would uh show whether
or not it was actually given to anyone
they said oh we lost it so yeah and
there was that weird moment when Richard
Nixon after visiting Tain gave a speech
where he said I don't know I really love
you all I'm I'm jokeing would be like
that I didn't know what this I should
have put in my book darn yeah in another
reality so that takes us through the 50s
then yes um so MDMA pops up again in
police records of seizures in around
1970 1971 um which probably just points
to the fact that the controlled sub
Substances Act had just come out and had
criminalized MDA which is closely
related molecule and um entrepreneurial
chemists are probably just looking for a
way to get around the law by sticking an
extra methyl group on poof MDMA um so uh
the police even thought that they were
seizing MDA but we don't know anything
about those chemists we don't know who
their customers were we don't know who
was using it for what uh what we do know
is that MDMA comes up again in
1975 when a uh PhD student at Berkeley
named Carl resnikoff uh got with his
mentor there a guy named Alexander
schulen everyone calls him Sasha a a
famous psychedelic chemist and they were
working on a summer project together and
um Carl shulan is kind of the Thomas
Edison of psychedelics right he just
great started proliferating all sorts of
compounds and oh yeah testing them out
incredible chemist yeah invented like 20
molecules would test them on himself and
his wife if they were interesting and
share them with friends um so Carl Young
Carl was really enamored with shulan and
his work because Carl um he had tried
LSD when he was like in eighth grade he
was all about it um and shulan said okay
you need to do a summer project what do
you want to do and Carl was a big fan of
MDA as we were talking about earlier and
thought okay um methan phetamine is more
euphoric than plain amphetamine the
difference is this methyl group why
don't I just stick this same methyl
group onto MDA and see what happens it's
pretty logical and you know shogun's
like that's a great idea let's do it so
they hold up in the summer of 1975 UC
Berkeley and synthesized MDMA together
and shogan took uh most of it home but
he gave Carl a little baggie measured
out just perfectly I think it was like
125 milligrams two doses um and Carl and
his girlfriend Judith wound up taking it
um on a beautiful September Day on a
boat ride across
the San Francisco Bay to selo and it's a
beautiful Recreation you have him tell
that story and it's it's really kind of
magical um there are moments where MDMA
is you know it's sometimes it's that
drug where it's like it's something you
do by yourself or with you know a loved
one or somebody you want to connect with
on a and when I say intimate not
necessarily sexual but like a deep
bond um and then it becomes kind of the
ultimate Rave well club drug first and
then Rave drug what how does how does it
start shifting out from that right well
back up just a step um before that so
shogan did try MDMA after call reported
back with very positive experiences in
76 and he realized this molecule's
potential for therapy yeah he introduced
it to a therapist friend of his who
became sort of this I guess people say
the Johnny apple seed of MDMA in the
Therapeutic Community so it quietly
started spreading among um first Bay
Area therapists then broader around the
US and even internationally but people
were keeping really quiet about it
because a lot of these therapists had
either worked with LSD in the preceding
decades or knew exactly what had
happened with LSD being criminalized so
they knew that if word got out about
this new psychoactive drug it would
absolutely be criminalized just like LSD
and they didn't want that to happen
because they were seeing such powerful
results how did they use it in a
therapeutic context yep so there's some
early studies um from the Greers out of
New Mexico and um you know at first it's
kind of funny they were following the
LSD model but at first they were kind of
just experimenting themselves with what
worked what didn't work and um in those
original trials they would actually take
MDMA with their clients but they
realized okay we need to not be high on
MDMA because we need to focus on you and
not make this about us so that stopped
um but they would bring people kind of
like the trials today um bring people to
their house give them a low or whatever
dose they thought would be appropriate
and just let them work through whatever
issue they were trying to work through
and the idea is I mean it it opens
people up it allows them
to you know be in touch with their
feelings and feel connected exactly yeah
it's kind of well shogan used the word
window so it opens this window on
yourself where you can find answers um
to questions you're asking your own self
or Partners um without fear without
anxiety without the typical Neurosis or
clutter of our brain that gets in the
way um so yeah people used it for all
kinds of things from couples counseling
to just uh you know I'm having this
trouble at work I want to work through
that I Want To Know Myself deeper um to
more uh serious things like trauma yeah
so that was all going on through the 70s
um but as you said earlier MDMA did make
this jump from the therapist couch to
the dance Flor and um the Greer said to
me in one point in the interview you
know it was inevitable that this was
going to happen it's a drug that makes
you feel good people want to take your
drugs to make you feel good um and there
was a lot of tension between the
recreational and the Therapeutic
Community just as there was with LSD
years before you know some people and I
guess we should point out that LSD
particularly during the 50s and early
60s to some degree was being used widely
by therapists to help you know just to
help treat things alcoholism but just to
get through things you know yesterday uh
while we're taping this yesterday was
Carrie Grant's birthday and Carrie Grant
is probably the best known kind of
celebrity who took LSD and publicly
extolled its virtues you know saying
like it made him feel alive again Etc so
MDMA is kind of an echo of that exactly
yeah and I mean it was really the LSD
therapist that paved the way for MDMA to
then just slot right into that yeah
guess empty pole that had been left by
LSD being criminalized and the thing is
at this time MD May is completely legal
the government isn't aware of it um so
there's these the Therapeutic Community
and many of them wanted to keep it a
secret and you know only a thing that
you know a you know friends tell friends
you can't like just spread it around a
club but there's also u a different
contingent of people who wanted to just
release it on the world and also make a
nice profit in doing so also similar to
LS State really indeed um so the the
sort of figurehead of the recreational
scene at this time was a guy named
Michael kle um he ran a group that came
to be known as the Texas group because a
lot of them were operating out of Dallas
and um Michael CLE just wanted to you
know churn out as much MDMA as possible
as quickly as possible making a lot of
money um but he wasn't the typical you
know drug lord that you think of like
you know I'm just going to like get
everyone hooked and make their money he
he had these ideas of himself as um
enlightened wanting to like serve a
bigger purpose in the world wanting to
like help people be saved you know
whatever that means to them um so that
was Michael K he uh really spread MDMA
across Texas California the us and that
is what attracted the attention of the
US government right so then what
happened then what happened um well the
DEA moved to schedule MDM may they in
summer of 885 which is when I was born
coincidentally um MDMA was put on the
emergency schedule one list and that
meant that it was illegal um well the
DEA what they did not see coming they
thought this would just be a normal
scheduling is that there were all these
therapists um professors like at Harvard
who believed in MDMA and thought it was
worthy of study and worthy of use so
this group of therapists including Sasha
shulan put together a case to bring the
da to court and say hey this is a drug
with medical purpose so it can't be
schedule one because you know schedule
one is defined as no medical potential
or no medical purpose right um it should
be schedule three allow us to work with
it allow us to study it you know control
it but you know come on uh and the
Really fascinating thing is they
actually won that trial the um
administrative law judge sided with them
and said yeah you guys have shown that
MDMA does indeed have value as a
medicinal tool it's being used by
therapist it should be schedule three um
but because of like whatever bureaucracy
I don't understand the like federal
system um MDMA uh was put on schedule
one because that judge's uh
determination was only a suggestion so
the da just did what they wanted to do
the whole time yeah um I am old enough
to have taken MDMA before it was illegal
and after and one of the things I I have
a I have a strong memory of it being
before uh in the in the earlier 80s it
was more of a kind of reflective
introspective drug and then after it
became illegal and you know part of the
concerns about it were like it was
dangerously antisocial like you didn't
wanted to go out or talk to people
because you were doing your own thing oh
post uh post prohibition it was like
it's the biggest thing that was a
problem about it is that it made you
dangerously social where you would go
out and dance all night kill yourself
like you would you couldn't stop and you
were part of a hive mind Etc which is
just kind of bizarre but so uh talk
about Maps uh the the nonprofit that is
the the group that is bringing you know
has been working since the 80s to bring
MDMA assisted Psychotherapy for PTSD and
related indications how did they get
involved and what role did they play in
this world where MDMA has been and band
right um so I'll say that we would not
be where we are today in terms of MDMA
assisted therapy being on the cusp of
potential Federal approval if it were
not for maps the multi-disciplinary
association for psychedelic studies maps
was founded in
1986 by a guy named Rick doblin um Rick
was this kid who grew up outside Chicago
raised on you know stories around the
family dinner table of the Holocaust so
Rick was this kid who was afraid that at
any moment all the people around him
could just break out into like a
maniacal genocide mode and Rick really
made it his mission in life he's a
strange kid apparently to find a
solution adult to yeah just a strange
guy yeah it's very interesting unique
character um Rick uh wound up at new
college in Florida where he was
introduced to drugs and he thought that
doing you know mind melting doses of LSD
Etc was the way to enlightenment he did
not find the answers um that route but
through uh those connections he found
his way to MDMA and at first he thought
it was like oh you know how profound
could this drug be if you can still talk
on it um but he quickly realized for
himself the utility of just being able
to communicate with people in the open
way we were talking about earlier and he
thought huh maybe this drug is the
answer for getting people to set aside
their differences and seeing that we're
all just human we all want love we all
want the same thing we have more in
common we have different um Rick got
involved in that DEA trial he was one of
the three um younger people that was
sort of spearheading the organizational
effort you know getting the money
getting the lawyer getting everyone to
write letters um after the trial
everyone gave up most people stopped use
uh using MDM in their practice because
they didn't want to lose their license
uh Rick was the one person who did not
give up and everybody thought like
you're an idiot like you're wasting your
time you're wasting your money it's just
a matter of time until you two you know
see the writing on the rall this is not
coming back um but Rick just is like
very hard-headed I guess like the most
tenacious person ever um and there was
something that Rick actually learned at
the trial he was talking with one of the
DEA agents who was representing the
government and this guy Frank Sapienza
told Rick look kid like there might be
something to this MDMA thing but you are
never going to get anywhere with it
unless you go through the Federal route
you need to get approval you need to do
FDA trials um clinical trials like
that's the way you got to do it and Rick
really took that to heart so he founded
maps to see that through and you know
it's taken like 38 plus years but like
you know blesses hard and so part of his
one of the lessons he talks about
learning from kind of the LSD experience
or or the the way the War on Drugs
started playing out when you know I mean
it had been around before but when Nixon
announced it in the early early 7s is
like that Outlaw route's not going to do
it we're going to try and go through
official channels um and where are they
now to uh like you know for FDA approval
of uh uh MDMA assisted Psychotherapy you
know what what's the status of that yep
so um clinical trials you have to have
three phases phase one is the first just
to show like okay this isn't going to
kill like a bunch of rats and people
phase two is kind of more efficacy and
safety and then phase three is the more
rigorous like okay does this work and is
it safe um they have just completed the
end of the phase three section and again
this has taken like literally 20 plus
years um you know just in terms of
paying for these things so we'll get to
this in a second but Rick was just doing
this all on fundraising you know and it
costs Millions literally to do clinical
trials um and also just jumping through
all the paperwork and permissions who of
the government um so the second or the
last phase three trial is done and Maps
um public benefit corporation which has
now become a pharmaceutical company just
submitted a application to the um FDA at
the end of December asking for a New
Drug approval for MDMA syst therapy for
PTSD so the fdda has like a certain
amount of time to respond but long story
short um hopefully there'll be some sort
of answer by like mid 2024 that's the
Year we're in now yes um parallel to
that kind of maps trying to get um MDMA
in certain circumstances approved what
happened you know in the 80s and 90s and
two in a with MDMA because right it you
know Timothy Larry once famously talked
about how LSD escaped you know the CIA
Labs you know Etc and went into the
mainstream MDMA certainly escaped any
kind of you know lock down on it um what
was going on there yeah um a lot was
going on so in the late 80s MDMA made
its way to the UK which basically
created Raves because people wanted to
keep partying after Clubs closed and uh
hence Raves and raves in turn led to the
multi-billion dollar electronic dance
music industry that we have today um
MDMA through that Rave pathway became a
global phenomenon so like tons of people
doing MDMA mostly youngsters um
warehouses clubs potentially dangerous
environments and we started to see our
first MDMA deaths um you know nothing
like the number of alcohol deaths we see
or other drugs but you know a few deaths
that would be overly covered in the news
and uh and this is from people kind of
taking too much and having cardiac
events or dehydrating and kind of Dance
I mean they were like whir they would be
talked about as whirling dervishes right
who would dance themselves to death yeah
I mean hyperthermia was the main One
overheating just you know getting too
hot and like yeah overheating um so MDMA
became this like hysterical news study
or news story you know ecstasy is
killing our children it was seen as this
threat to uh sort of puritanical
American and likewise British values um
so there were tons of just really um
severe laws that came down Banning Jo
Biden was inv the Rave act trying to
criminalize pacifiers and glow sticks as
drug paraphernalia for example um but
what that did is it really tarnished
mdm's reputation almost in the same way
as lsd's reputation was tarnished by
being attached to the counterculture you
know it was a like a you know political
strategy to try to take this drug down
and um at the same time the US
government especially was pumping money
into studies to prove that MDMA was
neurotoxic that it harmed that it
impacted the brain in a detrimental way
millions of dollars of federal funding
went into Labs you know L literally
trying to prove this um and in the end
they didn't prove it because MDMA really
isn't neurotoxic it it of course can be
dangerous if you take too much but the
lasting effect of that from the late 80s
and through the 90s and even early as
was that mdm's reputation was really
tainted um any public understanding or
awareness of its therapeutic value was
completely paved over by this negative
connotation and you know it's that kind
of connotation that I grew up with in
the ' 80s but then you know it it's kind
of flipped right because I mean there
was that story but then people were like
you know what I actually I feel really
good on this or I've had good
experiences um when did things seem to
start tipping away because I would say
now ecstasy is um you know it it doesn't
have those negative connotations that it
might have had at the beginning of the
21st century yeah I absolutely agree
well I can tell you my personal
experience of when it flipped um so I
wrote this book proposal in the pandemic
like I told you and my agent sent it out
to a bunch of editors and we got all
knows people were saying Michael pollen
already wrote this book because they
just don't understand the difference
between a mushroom and MDMA or whatever
um other people were saying this this
book looks too positive about MDM or
about ecstasy why isn't this about the
negative effects of ecstasy um and
others were saying there's not enough
there to say anything about ecstasy this
isn't a book project then the first Maps
phase three study came out I wrote about
it for the New York Times suddenly the
conversation just shifted in this really
um significant way yeah I started
getting interest on the book proposal um
I really think that that that trial kind
of legitimized MDMA and put it out there
in the broader public understanding in a
way that um wasn't present before um
what are the what are the the benefits
of the maps approach of going through
FDA approval and showing this is a
medicine and it's you know it it's like
other types of drugs you might help to
you know get over depression or anxiety
or something like that those are the
benefits are there costs to ebdm Bay
kind of being talked about oh well it's
it's a medicine and you go to a doctor
and you get prescribed and things like
that I have heard people who you know
are more part of the underground scene
and they're afraid that oh you know this
is going to make MDMA less cool if it's
you know suddenly this this medicine or
oh we're sterilizing the industry but um
I'm just remembering a comment that Ben
Sessa who's a um a therapist or
psychiatrist in the UK and also works
with MDMA and other um drugs like this
he's like you know like I can put on my
white coat and then I can go to a rave
you know whatever it doesn't make MDMA
less cool but this is what we have to do
to legitimize it to like eventually move
toward hopefully legality not just for
therapeutic uses but also for
recreational uses or whatever people
want to do and you know that's going to
make these things safer in the end
because then we're going to know where
we're getting our drugs we're going to
know how to take them we're going to
have education about how to use them
properly this is almost always the case
with what the government calls illicit
drugs not even illegal they're immoral
uh you know not knowing what's in them
which is hard to do in Black markets
because dealers don't spend a lot of
time putting labels on stuffed um or
checking the Providence but um a lot of
the times the impurities in a drug are
more terrible than whatever thing is
including things like heroin and whatnot
what is the um you know what's what's
the role of the Rave culture in kind of
popularizing or kind of create not I
don't want to say creating a market for
Ecstasy but like how does that work like
what are the cultural manifestations
that made people start to say not just
like like oh I'm going to stay away from
Ecstasy but actually that seems pretty
interesting I want to do it yeah try it
I think hearing your friends or people
you trust say hey I tried this thing and
Not only was it like the like most fun
night I've ever had it also was like a
profoundly beautiful experience yeah
that's actually how I found my way to
this drug um my now husband was a '90s
raver kid in Colorado going out to
warehouses and you know when I met him I
still had these negative connotations
about ecstasy and then hearing his
stories and he was by no means trying to
push me into this he was done with MDMA
um I was finally just like I want to try
this too like that sounds really fun um
you know and I think that we
really uh look over or um we don't give
the Rave scene it's due credit you know
millions and millions of people around
the world have tried MDMA M millions of
them have had profound beautiful
wonderful experiences on it yet there's
very little rigorous attention paid to
them you know from the scientific
Community there's just not funding or
interest to study them um because the
government is providing the mo most of
the St the funding and you know people
aren't dying on mass like they are with
meth or some other drug so I think
there's just so many interesting
questions to be mind there and you know
stories to be heard and then you have
like kind of underground movements that
come overground so you know burning man
is not certainly exclusively about MDMA
but that's part of the culture and The
Rave element of that or the Electric
Daisy Carnival I mean these are
festivals where being part of the the
throb right exactly yeah is is and you
you know as you point out in your
subtitle that question of looking for
connection um how is there a quick
explanation of how MDMA does that
because most people would agree that
it's like if you're in the right set and
setting and you take MDMA like you have
this sense you know people talk about an
oceanic sense of unity and whatnot and
it's it is beautiful it's very deep and
moving definitely I mean I think it
really serves the purpose of you know
these gatherings in the past that we
could rely on from religion or you know
mystical Gatherings or what whatever
that we really missing uh today and
people are seeking that out I mean I
know that's why I like to go to Raves
yeah in terms of what it's actually
doing I mean you know massive dumps of
Serotonin it not only um blocks your
receptors in your brain from taking up
serotonin which is the sort of Jack of
all trades neurotransmitter um does all
kinds of things but um your neurons
actually dump out their stores of
Serotonin something like 80% of your
serotonin floods your brain on a night
of MDMA or a day um oxytocin gets
triggered as well so there's just this
whole um chemical formula that's going
on in your brain to produce that feeling
yeah um how uh how do different
Generations
view or use MDMA differently and I'm
thinking you know there's somebody who
we interviewed uh years ago who I know
Charlie Wier and I know you know him and
a uh you know a a a therapist a
psychotherapist in his 7s who read a
book called listening to ecstasy echoing
listening to proac um you know do people
like that use MDMA in a different way
than you know people your age or or gen
Z great question I honestly I think it
more just comes down to an individual
preference so I I was going to bring up
Charlie you beat me to it um you know
Charlie and his uh Community oftentimes
use MDMA and a way to they dance they
have a great time but they also connect
on this um you know with spoken word
they share their traumas they um they
find group healing through talking I
tried that and I cannot talk like I just
want to dance um that's just me but I
know people my age are younger who also
you know prefer to be at home and just
like chat and put on some nice music so
I really think it just it's who you are
and it might be you know what you're in
the mood for how do you think uh MDMA
specifically fits into the larger kind
of resurgence of
psychedelics yeah well I do think that
MDMA is Paving the way through this
potential um FDA approval I think all
things look good for MDMA to be the
first psychedelic over that finish line
so you know that is absolutely major
yeah um you know I think MD man away it
hasn't held things back but you know
returning to that stigma and that taint
we talked about of the90s and 2000s and
I think that was a really big obstacle
to overcome um in a way that mushrooms
didn't have to overcome because they
just didn't have that same right like
negative connotation that MDMA or LSD
had I mean you never hear anything about
LSD hardly at all um MDMA you know I
hear less about than I hear mushrooms
like I was reading UC Berkeley's
newsletter today the micro do and it's
like oh Indiana's moving to um you know
invest dollars in psilocybin research on
PSD and this and that but you don't the
states aren't as eager to do MDMA which
you know I think it is the connotations
the stigma from earlier decades and um
also referring back to that synthetic
issue that you mentioned you know for
some reason people are more comfortable
with you know a natural substance than
one that was made legalizing nature
meaning I mean there's a lot of
movements to just say plant-based ethnog
gens or or certain types of
psychedelics I maybe it's their harder
to regulate because they could grow
anywhere but yeah we have this I I think
it's an artificial distinction between
nature and artifice yeah I 100% agree
with that um but at the same time I
think MDMA is just such a useful and
Powerful tool for therapy just because
it's um it's such an an easier medicine
to work with or or substance I guess I
mean it's like I I would assume I've
never actually done it in a a strictly
therapeutic setting but it's I don't
know it's like having Nova cane before a
filling or something like it just it
primes you to to do the have the work
done right that's perfect yeah exactly
it's just this Catalyst to make
everything work better why um in the the
kind of broad psychedelic space and you
know some people will be pedantic and
say well MDMA is not quite you know is
not really a psychedelic Etc but there's
seems to be an appreciation for a bunch
of substances which realistically very
few people use uh you know the number of
people who report using you know LSD or
MDMA or mushrooms in the past year are I
mean in the very low single digits of
people over the age of 18 um why are we
why does there seem to be so much
interest in this I mean it's definitely
changing these things the laws seem to
be changing and there's a cultural
moment where a lot of serious people are
talking about this a lot of creative
people are talking about this cultural
you know kind of artifacts of this stuff
are coming out all over the place what's
going on definitely I think it's a
complex mix so I think people are just
fed up with the War on Drugs they're
beginning to realize like just how
idiotic it was that there's no way to
you know win this war just what a waste
of money and lives and you know
environment you know the list goes on uh
I think people also have come to realize
that the quick chemical fix that we were
hoping would come through um psychiatric
drugs isn't working you know there's
more and more people suffering from
things like depression anxiety trauma
you know the list goes on they're
looking for other answers um and then a
little bit more cynically I think people
like the idea of this like magic wand
Cur all and they're just like oh gosh
you know psychedelics are going to like
me of all my problems they're going to
do what Prozac failed to do exactly and
people want you know to believe in these
magic cures and you know it's not going
to be that for most people so do you you
know a parallel with Maps they're a bit
behind it but uh Compass Pathways a
pharmaceutical company has gotten uh
they're pushing
psilocybin uh trials for depression and
anxiety with the FDA um is there is that
a good sign or a bad sign that you
know U you know that big pharmaceutical
companies are kind of starting to circle
around this and be like okay there's a
real opportunity yeah I mean I think
unfortunately it was just inevitable um
you know if it's great that they're
pushing trials through to get these
medications to people um you know the
monetization of it isn't great but it's
just this is the system we live in and I
don't think that sead delics were ever
going to be able to reform the system
you know Rick doblin was hoping that he
could get MDMA over the Finish Line with
uh charity alone and I mean incredibly
he raised 140 million plus dollarars on
Don ations um and then he even says
himself that uh he was sort of a um a
victim of his own success because by uh
helping bring the Psychedelic
Renaissance about through Maps suddenly
we have these companies like Compass
pump popping up that are for profit and
then donors are like why would I give
you free money that I'm not going to see
a return on when I can make an
investment over here um so Maps isn't
going to make it over the Finish Line
with MDMA um as a um philanthropy funded
product they just spun out a
pharmaceutical arm that is for-profit
they have a board they have investors
you know they tried really hard not to
but this is just the system that we live
in it's also fascinating because and I
know Maps is doing this by tying it with
therapy but most of these substances and
I guess this is true of some
Pharmaceuticals not all but like the
actual pills you know cost pennies to
make um but then it's hard to actually
kind of monetize it and that's you know
there's ketamine therapy which is kind
of related to this where the ketamine is
is effectively 0er and then the other
stuff is where the money is going to be
and that presents challenges for the
existing structure because
pharmaceutical companies make money
selling pills not selling pills attached
to six we therapy session or something
like that yeah do you what do you see
any um uh big obstacles in you know the
next couple of years to the um
medicalization and or legalization of
these substances I
mean I'm sure there's going to be some
kind of bureaucratic whatever I mean
there's a lot of positive s um signs
from the federal government that they're
into this you know Biden released some
memo about it there's um language in a
new bill about veterans for
investigating this um but you know I
just the the government is very very
conservative so I can see there being
all kinds of like hitches that you know
delay this like years but I think we
need to full to bring it all full circle
and who knows who's going to be
president next year but if you know it's
Nixon who started the current War on
Drugs went to China as a you know an
anti-communist Biden as the drug Warrior
he's he needs to go to the Electric
Daisy Carnival right and end it I Endor
this yeah okay everyone you heard it
here yeah um all right well we're going
to stop there the book is I Feel Love uh
the is Rachel newerth thanks for talking
thanks so much for having me it was
[Music]
delightful